και όταν αλλάζζαμε την ουσία να άρθουμε να προσθέσουμε το κερασάκι που είναι αν αλλάξουμ
την ικών όχι το αντίθετο πολλές φορές στην κύπρο δυστυχώς κάπνούμε το αντίθετο πάμε ν
αλλάζουμε την ικόνα αλλά κάτω από την ικών αν είναι όλα τα ίδια εμείς νιώθουμε
και είναι θεμαφιλοσοφίας αυτό το πράμα ότι πρώτα παράγουμε το εργο πρώτα παραδίδουμε κάτι και
μετά πάμε να το ανακοινώσουμε νι να κάνουμε την αλλαγή στην ιγόνα αυτόν καναμε προσφοτα
δηλαδή μετά από πέντε χρόνια μεγάλων αλλαγων είτε τεχνολογικών είτε μπορικών είτε στο ανθρώπινο δυναμικών
κρίναμε ότι πλέον οι οικόνα που είχαμε από το δύο χιλιάδες οκτώ δε ν αντιπροσωπεύει
το περιεχόμενο που έχουμε δημιουργήσει και θέλαμε κάτι καινούριον ένα περιτύλιγμα γύρω από το περιεχόμενο
το οποο να είναι αντιπροσωπευτικόν σε αυτό που είναι ισίδ και αυτό που κάναμε ένα
καινούργιο λόγο το οποίον όμως να μηνείνι πολύ διαφορετικών από το προηγούμενον ν να διατηρά
τις σύνδεση μ το ότι είναι ισίδα τιαξίες έχεισίδα και ένανέος λόγαν το ένα με
σε ένα το οποίο τον ίζει της σύνδεση μας με τους πολίτα με τους πολίτες
με τος πελάτες μας με τον κόσμουμε την κοινωνία με τις εταιρείες ότι είμαστε ένα
μαζί τους και ότι τους καταλαβαίνουμε και θα είμαστε δίπλα τους σε ότι θέλουν να
κάνου νιώσαμε ότι αυτόν είναι ι κατάλελη στιγμή για να περάσουμ υτόν το μήνυμα το
οποίο μπορούμε και υποστηρίζουμε πλέο όμως διαυτό το ένα μεσένα το υποστηρίζουμε με τις υπηρεσίες
μας με τις συμπεριφορά μας προς τους πελάτες με τον τρόπο με τον οποίον ο
κόσμος μας λειτουργοί εντος του οργανισμό όλα αυτά χτίζουν το οικοδόμημα που λέγεται ι σίδα
του διολιας κροστεςένα μεσέναν όπως υπάρε και τολόκαντη της νέας εστρατίας σας ένα μεσένα ισίαμε
τους πολίτες ισίτα προσπαθεί να επιστρεφεί πίσω στην κοινωνία πράγματα νομίζω ότιηςσίτα έχει να νιανανδίς